great well welcome back everyone i hope
you had a rapid fire session in your
breakouts uh there's so much to learn um
about activities and research
and ways to protect our planet that are
going on across the commonwealth um and
across the nation uh so i hope you
enjoyed uh the breakout sessions
um again this event it has been recorded
and will be available to everyone who
registered for a actually for a full
year so you can if you missed something
or wanted to see another session uh
please feel free you will have access to
log in and come back and review the the
sessions that that you missed um so we
greatly appreciate your attendance today
um and joining us in celebrating um
the legacy of dr john p wyatt
we want to extend our appreciation to
you as an audience and offer we're gonna
do a drawing of a raffle for um dr
frumpkin's book planetary health which
just hit the
um the market it's available but we're
going to provide it to
we haven't decided how many of our
attendees but you can
fill out the evaluation
and indicate that you'd like to receive
it and give us the contact and then
we'll um
we'll
hopefully be sending one to you very
soon
so i want to again um thank
everyone and every group who has
contributed today
as you can see from the breakout session
and our panelists we have a tremendous
strength and environment here at the
university of kentucky and also our deep
appreciation for the john p wyatt family
who has made this event possible
so we have a special event coming right
now which is a
a community engagement
award that the uk cares and the center
for
our excellence in rural health provides
collaboratively
um it recognizes individuals
and or a community academic team
that demonstrate outstanding achievement
and commitment to a community engagement
in a project that has deep relevance to
appalachian health
and so specifically for our region
so there were numerous uh nominations
from the community um we had a there was
also a panel of individuals who reviewed
these to select
uh the
winner so we have with us um aaron
savage who's going to present the
nominees and then also the winner of
this award
so it's my privilege to introduce to you
aaron savage she's the program manager
for the regional non-profit appalachian
voices
and in that role she works to address
the impacts of surface coal mining on
communities and the environment
today she's presenting on behalf of uk
cares where she's the co-chair of the
stakeholder advisory board
so erin i turn it over you to introduce
the nominees and also the award winner
thanks aaron
um
yes can you hear me
you sound great yes the sound is good
great
excellent um sorry about my internet
living in a rural place so um the
nominees for this year's award are
the east kentucky water network dr
beverly may program manager for the
mountain air project
the usa drone port
and kentucky watershed watch
and i am very pleased to present this
award to someone i will talk to you
since i began my work around central
appalachia 10 years ago the award goes
to derbez may
this is where the audience goes wild
congratulations
congratulations bev what an honor to
receive that and we're this is a
delightful occasion to give you um this
award today so
we need an audio track
can can clapping
congratulations
all right
uh thank you so much aaron for
presenting that award and again this is
the final thank you everyone who
participated uh please complete your
application or your
uh apply if you're a community member to
the award for next year
and also hopefully you can join us again
for this
another outstanding event so thank you
all and do complete your evaluations
take care have a great afternoon happy
earth day